21h elle brigue et pour accueillir le
public
pour sa première soirée sous son nouveau
nom la commanderie donner au public des
étoiles plein les yeux nous faisons une
blanche une manifestation nationale pour
faire reconnaître tout ce qui est dans
le domaine de la culture
les acteurs du territoire qui sont en
résidence chez nous mais qui en même
temps développe dans leur parti dans
leur arrêt tout qui développe ce que
représente l'art de vivre et le et le
territoire de 50 à une soirée placée
sous le signe du corps humain du
mouvement
un corps humain qui devient
constellation avec sa nouvelle
installation
l'artiste ma faute parce nous entraîne
au coeur de la voûte céleste
[Musique]
l'or existent parce que l'être et là au
coeur et interagit avec elle ce qui
m'intéresse parce que elle est toujours
renouvelées elles se comportent de façon
différente en fonction des comportements
w c'est vraiment l'intention de tuer les
corps stellaire c'est avec la structure
de notre squelette qui est détecté par
caméra infrarouge arriver à ce que
chacun crée sa propre constellation et
qu'elles soient enregistrées dans un
ciel étoilé virtuel cette nuit blanche
était aussi l'occasion de lancer la
nouvelle exposition de l'atelier des
sciences elle est à découvrir jusqu'au
25 novembre